so former Trump campaign manager Corey
Lewandowski remember that guy he was on
Fox News the other day and he dismissed
an anecdote about a ten year old girl
with Down syndrome being put in a cage
as part of this policy of putting in
internment camps separated from their
parents migrant children detained at the
border and it went completely off the
rails when he used the sad trombone meme
in audio style during this appearance on
Fox News check this out I mean look I
read today about a ten year old girl
with Down syndrome who was taken from
her mother and put in a cage a ten year
old so womp-womp really sent it off the
rails and if you're not familiar with
that it's sort of a trolling satirical
sad trombone audio meme let's just play
it just so you know what the reference
is not exactly empathetic right why your
kid with Down's syndrome was put in a
cage what else are you gonna cry about
but this is for real like this this is
actually what is being said by former
Trump associates on national television
the next day Corey Lewandowski was asked
whether he wants to apologize and he
said why would I apologize and as crazy
and lacking empathy as this is the
really disturbing thing is that it's not
the want want specifically but it's the
broader campaign to paint what's going
on is not worthy of our concern that we
should be horrified by right because
it's Corey Lewandowski with a womp womp
about ten year-old girl with Down
syndrome in a cage it's Fox News host
Laura Ingraham likening the child
internment camps to summer camps it's
Jeff Sessions saying it's not like the
Nazis what we're doing
because the Nazis didn't deport people
and we also deport people it's an entire
campaign of not just trying to
delegitimize the arguments of those who
opposed the child internment policy but
it's an attempt to deal Ajith amaizing
emotions of the political opponents and
this is a tool a tool used by right-wing
trolls the facts don't care about your
feelings right that's an increasingly
popular phrase among some on the right
calling anybody who feels affected by
something a snowflake who's been
triggered and framing emotion as sort of
evidence of weakness it's not just
trolling it's a very specific type of
opposition campaign and that's why it's
actually not risky for Lewandowski or
Trump or whoever to do something like
saying want want they know that lots of
their supporters have bought into this
triggered snowflake stuff yeah and he's
speaking directly to them there will be
no consequences for corey lewandowski
from effectively jokingly dismissing
with a trolling meme the caging of a 10
year old girl with Down syndrome at
least they're not pretending anymore
they're not trying to act as if family
separation bothers them before they were
saying that oh this is an Obama policy
and Congress can stop it immediately
ya know now that I just admit how they
actually feel if nothing else they're
consistent right because Corey
Lewandowski want whomped a girl with
Down syndrome put in a cage and Donald
Trump made fun of a disabled reporter
and it's all actually super consistent
consistent and I don't know how you
fight people who have no moral compass
or at least not a moral compass that
resembles anything we'd recognize as a
moral compass there's one solution I'm
not even going to say it because I've
said it so many times with the solution
is and max knows what it is and you all
know there's one solution to this
problem and it's a solution that we can
make a reality in a particular month of
the year that is the same month that
contains Thanksgiving but I'm not
actually going to tell you what the
solution is